this is a cbs news special report i'm
anthony mason in new york right now the
government
is releasing two key reports that will
shed new light on how the economy is
being hammered by the pandemic
we're expecting an historic drop in
america's gross domestic
product gdp that's the broadest measure
of the country's economic strength
analysts say the economy is in serious
trouble right now we're also going to be
getting new numbers on how the pandemic
is affecting the job market the labor
department just reported
another 1.4 million americans filed for
unemployment last week this comes as
congress remains deadlocked over another
stimulus package
to boost the economy and help people
who've lost their jobs
let's bring in cbs news business analyst
jill schlesinger jill let's start with
the gdp report
what that what does that tell us well
first of all gdp
that is the total measure of the u.s
economy goods and services and we
saw a historic contraction in the second
quarter
down by just under 33 percent
on an annualized basis now just to
remind everyone because you don't study
econ 101 every day
33 doesn't mean we drop by a third over
one quarter from another it means that
if we were going to push this through
for the next four quarters it would be a
33 percent drop
this amounts to about a 10 drop from the
previous quarter
it is awful still just remember the
worst performance that we have seen
since records have been kept back in
1947
anthony this does sort of approach the
great depression era we didn't have
numbers at that time
but it's clear it was a devastating
contraction in the u.s economy and
that's what occurred
in the second quarter of the year yeah
and then that affected that of course
our job losses jill what do you make of
the unemployment number for the for the
quarter
well this is clearly just like jay
powell said yesterday the chairman of
the fed that the pace of the economic
recovery is following the virus
because we have seen a spike in cases
in the virus in the south and west we
sort of stopped short on the progress we
were making the weekly claims
so to have here in the 19th 20th week
since this all began to have another 1.4
million people applying for unemployment
it's staggering
more than 50 to 53 million people have
applied for benefits since the pandemic
reared its ugly head so how critical
does that make another stimulus package
joe
when i talk to economists they believe
that that
extra money that is going to people who
are sidelined in the economy right now
that that is imperative in fact we do
expect the economy will bounce back in
the second half of this year
estimates for you know say 13 to 18
increase in the quarter or in right now
but those estimates are predicated on
more help to americans and to small
businesses
without that help the economy could
really see
its its fortune sort of slide a little
bit in the second half of the year
again we've already started to recover
it looks like the worst
quarter is behind us but people will
need the help
and so too will the economy all right
jules lessinger thank you jill